welcome to Brooklyn New York it's not  the greatest place in the world but it's  where we live for now that's funny the  world's greatest gamers in this  apartment you can imagine I was like  seven eight years old and I was running  around the Bronx with my friends going  to our key to arcade playing the latest  game trying to get high scores my wife  was like what are you gonna do this  forever well I've got to put food on the  table I remember these guys are like  well I fix him  guys is like in their 20s and stuff and  they're all world champions  my father was talking to me about living  life and leaving remark in life what's  more important  don't look now video games video yeah